Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Vous avez été très nombreux à adorer
mon top cinq des animaux immortels.
Enfin, presque immortels.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai mieux à vous proposer.
Le top 5 des animaux
les plus dangereux de la planète.
Brrr , vous allez voir,
ça va être mortel.
Pour commencer,
direction l'Afrique.
C'est ici
que vit notre premier animal dangereux.
L'hippopotame.
À première vue,
c'est un herbivore
d'apparence plutôt placide.
Mais vous le savez,
il ne faut jamais se fier aux apparences.
En effet,
l'hippopotame est une créature à éviter
absolument.
Bien que ce ne soit pas un prédateur,
ce mammifère semi-aquatique
tue près de 500 personnes chaque année.
Le moins que l'on puisse dire,
c'est que son gabarit est impressionnant.
Un mâle adulte peut atteindre
5 mètres de longueur
et peser plus de 3 tonnes.
Cela fait de l'hippopotame
l'un des mammifères
les plus lourds de la planète,
après l'éléphant,
le rhinocéros ou la baleine.
Mais ce colosse a un point faible,
il est doté d'une très mauvaise vue.
C'est un gros handicap pour un herbivore.
En effet, ceux-ci doivent être capables
de repérer leurs prédateurs de très loin.
Pour compenser,
l'hippopotame a donc développé
un comportement agressif
à l'égard de toutes celles
et tous ceux qui osent
s'aventurer sur son territoire.
Il attaque sans sommation
en dégainant son arme fatale.
Une mâchoire impressionnante
qu'il peut ouvrir à presque 180 degrés.
Celle-ci est truffée de dents
aux dimensions hors normes.
Les incisives inférieures
des mâles peuvent mesurer
30 à 40 centimètres.
Quant aux canines,
elles ressemblent à des défenses
mesurant près de 60 centimètres.
Vous l'avez compris,
si elles se referment sur sa victime,
elle n'a aucune chance de s'en sortir
vivante.
C'est dans les rivières,
où il passe le plus clair de son temps,
que l'hippopotame est le plus dangereux.
En eaux peu profondes,
il est capable de charger
à la vitesse de 30 kilomètres par heure.
S'il est aussi rapide, c'est parce
qu'en réalité il ne nage pas vraiment.
Il préfère galoper sur le fond.
Entre chaque enjambée,
le mastodonte pousse sur ses pattes
pour flotter dans l'eau.
Un peu comme un astronaute sur la Lune
qui se déplace en microgravité.
Mais n'allez pas croire que sur la terre
ferme,
vous êtes plus en sécurité.
L'animal a beau être lourd,
il n'en est pas moins leste.
Énervé,
il n'hésitera pas à vous courser et n'aura
aucune difficulté
à vous rattraper.
Sur une courte distance,
il peut atteindre la vitesse
de 48 kilomètres par heure.
C'est plus qu'Usain Bolt,
l'Homme le plus rapide du monde.
Au top de sa carrière,
le champion jamaïcain
ne dépassait pas
44,7 kilomètres par heure.
Alors si un jour vous croisez
un hippopotame, courage.
Fuyez,
avant qu'il ne soit trop près.
Quittons le continent africain,
direction l'Indonésie,
à l'autre bout du monde.
C'est ici que se cache
l'une des créatures les plus effrayantes
de la planète : le dragon de Komodo.
Comme son nom l'indique, ce reptile
vit sur l'île de Komodo.
On le rencontre également
sur les îles voisines de Rinca,
Padar et Florès.
En réalité, c'est un lézard.
C'est même le plus grand
lézard du monde.
Il peut dépasser les 3 mètres
et peser plus de 100 kilogrammes.
Je vous rassure, il ne crache pas de feu,
mais mieux vaut l'éviter.
Le dragon de Komodo, ou varan de Komodo,
est un prédateur féroce
qui ne fait pas de quartier.
Il dévore tout ce qui lui tombe
sous les griffes.
Serpents, petits lézards, oiseaux,
mais aussi cochons,
singes, chèvres, cerfs
et même les énormes buffles d'eau.
Son appétit est insatiable.
Pourtant, à première vue,
il n'a pas l'air si dangereux.
Regardez la gueule ouverte,
on peut même croire qu'il n'a
pas de dents.
Erreur.
Celles-ci sont enfouies dans ses gencives.
Elles mesurent environ 2,5 centimètres.
Ça ne semble pas énorme,
mais ne vous y trompez pas,
elles sont redoutables.
Ces dents sont aussi efficaces
que celles d'un requin blanc.
Très pointues, avec des bords dentelés,
elles sont de véritables couteaux acérés
qui découpent les proies
sans aucune difficulté.
Mais avant d'en arriver là,
le dragon doit d'abord
débusquer ses victimes.
Pour y parvenir,
il se sert de sa langue bifide.
Ce qui signifie fendue.
Elle capte toutes les particules
odorantes présentes dans l'air.
Elle agit comme un radar.
Une fois sa proie repérée,
le reptile se précipite
sur elle en courant.
Il peut atteindre 20 kilomètres par heure.
Il peut même nager si nécessaire.
Mais ce qui fait de notre gros lézard
l'une des créatures
les plus dangereuses de la planète,
c'est une arme secrète
qui se niche dans sa salive.
Un redoutable venin.
Lorsqu'il mord sa proie,
le dragon de Komodo
lui inocule au passage
un cocktail empoisonné.
Une fois dans le sang,
celui-ci provoque une forte chute
de la pression artérielle,
qui se solde par un arrêt cardiaque.
L'agonie peut durer des heures,
mais notre varan a tout son temps.
Une fois morte, il dévore sa proie en deux
temps trois mouvements.
Son seul point faible ?
Il n'est pas très endurant.
Le dragon se fatigue vite et passe
le plus clair de son temps à lézarder.
Dans la famille des reptiles,
j'en connais un autre qui n'a
aucune pitié
si vous croisez son chemin.
Euh ! (panique)
La simple évocation de son nom
donne le frisson.
Il s'agit du Mamba noir.
Un serpent a venin
considéré
comme le plus dangereux au monde.
Il est si terrifiant
que le personnage principal du film
Kill Bill, une tueuse
interprétée par Uma Thurman,
a été surnommée
Black Mamba, Mamba noir en anglais.
Il doit son nom à la coloration noire
de sa cavité buccale
et non à la couleur de sa peau
qui varie du jaune-vert
au gris métallique.
C'est le plus grand serpent
du continent africain.
Sa taille peut varier de 2 mètres 50
à plus de 4 mètres.
Léger, il est très agile dans les arbres.
C'est toutefois au sol
qu'il est le plus à l'aise.
Le Mamba est capable de se déplacer
à la vitesse de 23 kilomètres par heure.
C'est aussi rapide
qu'une trottinette électrique.
Mais son arme fatale,
c'est bien sûr son venin.
Une seule morsure
suffit à vous tuer en quelques minutes.
La neurotoxine qu'il contient, appelée
dendrotoxine,
agit rapidement sur le système nerveux.
Elle provoque une paralysie
des muscles respiratoires.
La victime finit par suffoquer,
puis elle meurt.
Il suffit de 10 à 15 milligrammes de venin
pour tuer un homme adulte.
Je vous rassure, le Mamba
s'attaque rarement à nous.
Lorsque ça se produit,
c'est uniquement
pour protéger son territoire.
Ce redoutable serpent préfère
déguster de petits mammifères
comme les rongeurs.
C'est plus facile à avaler.
Nous restons en Afrique,
sur les bords du Nil.
Ici.
C'est le plus long fleuve du continent
et c'est aussi le territoire
d'un redoutable prédateur.
Le crocodile du Nil.
Dans la grande famille des crocos,
c'est l'un des plus dangereux.
Il serait responsable
d'une centaine de morts par an.
Grand amateur de chair humaine,
il a la très mauvaise habitude
de rôder à proximité des villages.
À la moindre occasion,
il surgit et ne vous laisse aucune chance.
Ce géant compte
parmi les plus grands reptiles du monde.
Un mâle adulte peut mesurer
jusqu'à 5 mètres de long
et peser jusqu'à 750 kilogrammes.
Certains spécimens
sont carrément hors norme.
C'était le cas de Gustave,
un crocodile du Nil bien connu
pour avoir terrorisé
le Burundi dans les années 90-2000.
Il dépassait les 6 mètres
et pesait plus d'une tonne.
À lui seul,
ce bon Gustave aurait dévoré,
tenez vous bien,
plus de 300 personnes.
Pour saisir leurs proies,
ces superprédateurs ont une botte secrète.
Ils sont dotés
d'une mâchoire surpuissante.
Sa force est estimée à environ
2 tonnes par centimètre carré.
C'est 5 fois plus que le lion
et 30 fois plus que la morsure
d'un être humain.
Pourtant, ce monstre, qui terrorise
les riverains du Nil, ne pèse pas lourd
face à un autre prédateur
bien plus dangereux, l'Homme.
Le braconnage,
la déforestation et la pollution agricole
pourraient à court terme entraîner
l'extinction de l'espèce.
C'est un comble, car il fut un temps
où le crocodile du Nil était considéré
comme un dieu par les humains.
Dans l'Égypte antique, Sobek,
le dieu à la tête de crocodile,
protégeait les hommes
des crues
et assurait la fertilité des récoltes.
Les Nubiens,
une minorité ethnique présente en Égypte,
continuent d'ailleurs
de vénérer ce grand reptile,
au point que certains en font
même leur animal de compagnie.
Moi,
je me contenterai d'un chat ou d'un chien.
Notre 5 ème et dernier animal
est sans aucun doute
le plus redoutable de tous, en tout cas
le plus meurtrier.
Chaque année, il fait
plus de 750000 victimes dans le monde.
Là, je sens que je pique votre curiosité.
Et c'est bien normal puisque ce tueur
Ah non hein !
Vous l'avez compris, c'est le moustique.
En tant que tel, il n'a pas l'apparence
d'un assassin.
Mais ces petits insectes
qui se nourrissent de notre sang
peuvent transmettre
des maladies mortelles comme le paludisme
ou la fièvre jaune.
L'un d'entre eux a
beaucoup fait parler de lui
ces dernières années.
C'est le fameux moustique tigre
originaire d'Asie,
l'Aedes albopictus,
véhicule trois maladies
potentiellement mortelles
la dengue,
le chikungunya ou encore le virus zika.
Présent sur l'île de La Réunion
depuis pas mal d'années,
il a désormais envahi l'Europe,
à cause des échanges commerciaux.
En France métropolitaine, il est présent
dans 67 départements.
En 2021, 164 cas de dengue
et 3 cas de chikungunya
y ont été déclarés.
Pour l'immense majorité,
il s'agit de cas importés, autrement dit
des personnes qui ont été infectées
avant d'entrer
sur le territoire métropolitain.
Malheureusement, pour l'heure,
on ne parvient pas à l'éradiquer.
Plusieurs pistes sont à l'étude,
notamment une
qui consiste à relâcher dans la nature
des mâles rendus stériles.
Les mâles, qui ne piquent pas,
seules les femelles pompent notre sang,
empêcheraient puisqu'ils sont stériles,
la multiplication des moustiques.
Si vous avez tremblé de plaisir
devant ces redoutables créatures,
n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce bleu
ou à vous abonner à la chaîne.
Et surtout, faites-moi
la liste de vos envies
pour les prochaines vidéos.
Nous les lisons toutes.
À bientôt,
chères Épicurieuses et chers Épicurieux.